ahora hemos complicado más las cosas
tenemos otra vez nuestra masa misteriosa
en este caso tenemos tres masas
misteriosas que hemos llamado x pero
también tenemos esta vez en masas de un
kilogramo de este lado de la balanza la
balanza está en equilibrio y lo primero
que me gustaría hacer es invitarte a que
propongas una expresión algebraica que
iguale el escenario que tenemos frente a
nosotros te voy a dar unos segundos para
que lo pienses
del lado izquierdo tenemos tres masas x
que suman 13 x y 2 masas de un kilogramo
cada una o sea 2 kilogramos
otra forma de pensarlo es que la masa
total del lado izquierdo es 3 x 2 o sea
3 masas
x + 2 kilogramos 3 x + 2
ahora observemos que tenemos del lado
derecho vamos a contar tenemos 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 14 masas de un
kilogramo cada una así que la masa total
es 14 kilogramos también observamos que
la balanza está en equilibrio o sea
ninguno de los lados sube ni baja así la
masa total de ambos lados tiene que ser
la misma
entonces podemos poner el signo de igual
aquí no mejor lo voy a poner en blanco
si se ve mejor ahora pensemos ella sea a
través de la expresión algebraica o del
dibujo como podemos empezar a trabajar
esto por ejemplo empecemos pensando cómo
puedo quitar estas dos de un kilogramo
del lado izquierdo y te voy a dar unos
segundos para que lo pienses
bueno pues podríamos simplemente retirar
estas dos masas de un kilogramo del lado
derecho pero debes de recordar que si
nada más los quitamos del lado derecho
entonces este lado será más ligero y la
balanza ya no estará en equilibrio y ya
no podríamos utilizar el signo igual
lo que tenemos que hacer es quitar dos
de un lado y dos del otro lado y vamos a
hacerlo entonces quitamos dos de este
lado y dos de este lado
y matemáticamente lo que estamos
haciendo es restar dos kilogramos de
cada lado del lado izquierdo tengo 3 x 2
y le voy a restar 2 entonces sólo me
queda 3 x
y del lado derecho tengo 14 al que le
restó 2 y eso es igual a 12 sólo nos
quedará 12 y lo puedes observar como
quite 2 de un lado y quite 2 del otro
lado de este lado sólo quedaron 3 x y
nuestra ecuación ahora dice 3x es igual
a 12 y no está balanza sigue en
equilibrio lo que te quiero preguntar
otra vez y de hecho se parece mucho a
los ejercicios que hemos venido haciendo
es que podríamos hacer para aislar dejar
una sola equis del lado izquierdo y
mantener el equilibrio
me gustaría darte unos segundos para que
lo pienses
pues una idea bastante simple puede ser
en multiplicar el lado derecho por un
tercio osea si tengo 3x y lo multiplicó
por un tercio voy a quedar con una sola
equis pero tendré que también hacerlo
del otro lado osea multiplicar por un
tercio las masas que tengo del lado
derecho matemáticamente sería esto es
multiplicar el lado izquierdo por un
tercio pero si quiero mantener la
balanza en equilibrio también tengo que
multiplicar por un tercio el lado
derecho y físicamente esto de
multiplicar por un tercio sería el
equivalente a dejar nada más un tercio
de lo que se encuentra en cada lado de
la balanza entonces en este caso sería
quitar 2x del lado izquierdo para que
sólo quede una equis y del lado derecho
donde tenemos 12 bloques de un kilogramo
tendríamos que dejar sólo un tercio de
12 que son cuatro bloques de un
kilogramo ahora lo que tenemos será nada
más este bloque x que está aquí que
estoy indicando y de este lado cuatro
bloques de un kilogramo que también
estoy indicando
y matemáticamente lo que tenemos es que
un tercio que multiplica tres que es lo
mismo dividir a tres entre tres entonces
los tres se cancelan y me queda un equis
y del otro lado del lado derecho tengo
12 que está multiplicado por un tercio
que es lo mismo que dividir 12 entre 3 y
eso me queda 4 y como todos lo hicimos
de ambos lados de la balanza la balanza
sigue en equilibrio y entonces podemos
decir que la masa de x es igual a 4